Given how pejorative the term is, we’re
understandably keen to locate snobs somewhere
far from us. They are the people in the newspaper,
or the ones who live in the other part of
town or went to the school we didn’t go
to – but it’s nice not to imagine them
too near to home. Yet that’s to deny an
obvious eventuality: snobs may lie closer
to us. Snobs form couples; they have children.
And we might be among them. However painful
the unvarnished thought, we might be the children
of snobs. It’s a situation it can be therapeutic
to face up to and to try to make sense of.
Related image What is a snob? It has little
to do with an old-fashioned love of aristocracy.
A snob is simply someone without an independent
center of judgement, who can only value what
the ‘in’ group in society happens to esteem
at any point in time. Snobs’ opinions and
tastes might be quite sane (or not); the key
thing is that they aren’t their own. They
cannot tell what to make of anything until
other, prestigious voices have made up their
minds for them. There is a particular conundrum
that sets in when snobs have a child: how
should they evaluate this new creature, in
whom the world has no particular interest
and who cannot wow or dazzle it? The thing
merely sits in its cot, dribbles and screams
a lot. It cannot do, it can only be. The snobs’
first reaction is often to say that they don’t
‘like babies’ as a generic category. It
sounds innocent enough, but the distaste is
more fundamental: babies are unlikeable first
and foremost not because they are messy and
noisy, but because they are so unimpressive
in worldly terms. Image result for 1950s family
At heart, the snob suffers from low self-confidence,
which is why the incompetence of their own
small child is so galling, threatening to
evoke their own sense of fragility and vulnerability.
The baby can’t buy or sell a company, star
in a movie, or even drink neatly from a cup
– and may on this basis generate panic and
fury in their snobbish carers. Fortunately,
with a little time, school comes along – granting
snobs the perfect tool with which to manage
their feelings. Snobs make it very clear to
their offspring that doing well at school,
very well indeed, is not merely pleasing or
cautionary, it is quite simply essential.
Life more or less depends on it. There need
to be cups, prizes, trophies and high scores
in pretty much every subject. Doing well enough
isn’t enough; excelling is the goal. If
you don’t perform, you cannot be loved:
whether this is directly spelt out or merely
artfully suggested, this is the ideology under
which the offspring of snobs grow up. Unsurprisingly,
most children of snobs do very well at school.
And at university. And later on, in the job
market. A feeling that one doesn’t deserve
to exist unless one meets the criteria of
worldly success can do wonders for one’s
productivity. Offering conditional love has
a habit of getting people to meet one’s
conditions. Image result for 1950s office
But that is also why the children of snobs
are uncommonly likely to be on their way to
a nervous breakdown, which often sets in just
when most of the worldly boxes have been ticked.
The longing that one should be recognised
for being and not just doing – even if one
has done quite a lot – is an extremely stubborn
part of human psychology, which has a habit
of periodically rearing its head and creating
serious trouble if it keeps being ignored
across a lifetime. We may well be able to
meet conditions, but we can’t quite forget
the desire to be loved without them, simply
for being ourselves, in all our original messiness
and confusion. Through a breakdown, by deliberately
sabotaging what we have achieved in the world,
we may be trying to go back and taste a simple,
condition-less love that was denied to us
in the early years. We’re trying – at
huge cost – to re-experience a missing stage
of development. We are tired of decades of
making symbolic offerings under emotional
duress to the ghosts of emotionally withholding
parents. It might be better to sit in hospital
for a while and disappoint everyone. The more
we understand the risks we face, as children
of snobs, the less danger there will be of
having to act out our complaints. To be a
child of snobs is a diagnosis like any other
– and deserves its own taxonomy, treatment
and pathway to health. Part of this involves
overcoming anger towards one’s carers – and
realising that snobs are not evil, merely
wounded. As their child, one will have to
put extra effort into the delicate task of
finding oneself valuable and worthy outside
of achievement, not because of anything one
has said or done, but just because one exists
– which should always, of course, have been
enough.
The Joys and Sorrows of Parenting promises us a gentle way of staying calm around one of the most arduous yet deeply fulfilling jobs in the world.